[Music]
cnbc just printed this out nearly 40
percent of investors who pulled money
out of markets in the last year
regretted it
oh so you figured out that when you pull
money out of the market that it's a dumb
idea because you usually pull it out
when it's down so you bought high and
sold low that's kind of the opposite of
what you ought to be doing all right
well the stock market is crashing dave
don't you know yeah i do know i just
pulled it up just a second ago let me
just tell you what it says today let's
see here today
the stock market is down in the past 12
months day over day
12 exact months
seven and a half percent
that is not crashing
bitcoin is down 52
that is crashing that's a train wreck
okay that's a train over the mountain in
a black and white film wreck
okay
but that seven and a half percent is not
your 401 k became a 201k you didn't lose
all your money now it's down from let's
see the high points january the 4th it
looks like 36 000 almost 37 000 dow and
the dow's down around 31 right now so
it's down more than 7.5 since january
but over the last 12 months it's down
seven and a half that's not exactly a
crash
it's not good i'd rather be up 17
i'm not happy about that but it's not
exactly reason for you to panic
time is the ultimate weapon when it
comes to investing said matt schultz the
chief credit analyst at lendingtree
gives younger investors a huge advantage
over their older counterparts
uh unfortunately however gen z and
millennials risk squandering that
advantage if they pull their money out
of the market when times get tough let
me just help you with this map
all of you are stupid when you pull your
money out of the market when it gets
tough you don't have to be gen z
you can be uh maybe 50 60 70 years old
and you just go oh god and you sell low
that's just the worst possible time to
sell it ride the wave
trust that better times are ahead this
quote says and i agree with that ride
the wave so my quote always is those
that no one gets hurt on a roller
coaster except those that jump off in
the middle but here's an interesting
thing some 38 percent of investors said
they sold stocks last year due to a
current event
like extreme inflation ukraine whatever
according to a study from magnify money
of that group 40 percent
so they wish they hadn't done it
the online survey of more than 1 000 u.s
consumers was conducted in a on april
15th and the other 60 percent just uh
wouldn't admit it yeah it wouldn't they
would they haven't seen it they still
haven't looked
here's an interesting thing with the
fear that happens there
we've talked about this before where
there's psychological studies done that
say you have to gain three dollars
to feel like you broke even with a one
dollar loss
losses have more impact on your
psychology than gain does right more
negative impact than gain does positive
impact
and so in other words we all like you
know we all are
negative ninnies at our soul in some
sense you know and so uh
the thing that goes with that then
is this idea that that um
then they add a narrative
to it when they get out that is
hyperbole that's not true that's exactly
right okay so they say things like back
in 1987 black monday i lost everything
in the stock market
what do you what have you been listening
to your grandfather from the great
depression
you didn't lose everything
the stock market didn't go to zero
you had the money in mutual funds and it
went down 25
in one day but you didn't it didn't go
to zero it was a cataclysmic event it
was not a good day but it didn't go to
zero
and so you didn't lose everything what
happened was you pulled your money out
at the bottom and you felt really stupid
because you were
stupid for doing that and then you had
to make up this story that made it sound
like the stock market is the villain
right and that you just got off on a
lifeboat just in time yeah well and it
was just
no it's not you don't put money in there
because i lost everything back in the
day right back in the day whatever i had
all my money went got to zero and no it
didn't it's mathematically impossible
unless you had all your money in a
single company and that company went
completely broke and was liquidated and
they had no assets and the chapter 7
bankruptcy trustee couldn't sell the
assets and get a dime because that would
have been distributed to the
stockholders so i mean this is almost
physically impossible for you to get
absolutely zero now i lost a lot yeah or
i lost an amount that made me feel
really scared these are accurate
statements
but we have to add to this somehow to
put a stake in the ground
to somehow to create a story to offset
the fact that we know this was a bad
idea that's right and
nearly 70 percent of gen z investors
pulled money 70 7 at 10 they have only
known
this bull run for the last few years and
they don't know what even they don't
know the roller coaster goes down ever
right so here we are wait a minute it
goes down two who knew exactly so write
it out
right now this is exactly the wrong time
to sell oh by the way
the market's down that means it's on
sale
this is the time to buy more time to
sell